[Music]
in got the last laugh news a residue the
Joker don't tell me anything but then he
does those random ones that are like
yeah this was a random one
you sound like Mandark from Dexter
Dexter's Laboratory oh I went to Dexter
the serial killer Oh anyways in that
news submitted by bathrooms with free
lotion a dead man got the last laugh at
his funeral with an unexpected prank
that's tight what does he come up on
wires oh my god or he died with a boner
so when you open the coffin thing that
you have to pay attention to no one came
to his funeral
how did he get the last laugh oh he got
the last okay nevermind I'm like that's
me yeah so this man he he's an Irish man
ah he's a veteran for a Defense Forces
his name is or was Shea Bradley and so
this video went viral because of his
funeral because well always do che hai
re PR if you point out for you believe
yeah so he I think we died in combat or
something he passed away after he
survived Lucky Charms magically
delicious yeah so he passed away after a
long battle with an illness so like
cannon you coming up the prank yeah so
this is what the prank was there's a
video about II he pops out of the cup
coughing like I did full hello
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's pretty beat man
they really don't want him to climb out
pretty dark sense of humor but I didn't
think that was funny at all that was
pretty cute I could see that how how
it'd be funny in the moment cuz
everyone's all sad and crying and you're
like oh this [ __ ] that was hella
judging those old ladies I was like how
dare you laugh at a moment like like if
you were dead and then all of a sudden
your stupid recorder starts playing
you're like you know like people like
all that was his personality we get to
hear it one more time yeah all buggered
climb out of the coffin you if you guys
start laughing at me while I'm dead I'll
be like [ __ ] is a serious
moment let me play my [ __ ] and then
you'll have to suffer crying while you
hear my Kenny G sound where the [ __ ] is
my Kenny G sound dammit I'm buried it
went I think something to the effect of
oh I think it made me a little bit sad
cuz he was like let me out let me out
like I was hoping it'd be more of like a
joke like an instrument type of thing or
or something else you know not the let
me out some like oh I want you don't you
understand you forget what you bet yeah
or I thought there's gonna be like a
button to the joke right and he's like
not just kidding I'm dead see ya later
so ya know I am like a yeah I thought it
was gonna end it too quick I guess I'll
stay here then fine don't [ __ ] bury me
man and put me in ashes and blow me open
up [ __ ] firework I want to be gone I
don't have any chance of the upon B
apocalypse coming back he was knocking
I want to open day that's like what does
that have to do with the zombies no I
mean the taromenane
no Barret burn me for me to Sam and
caskets that's a scam they rip those
people off they're so expensive
funerals are just as costly as wedding
yeah
insane I'd rather what it provides
choice I'm dead I don't care about your
job how is he gonna go to the afterlife
if he's buried all ancient civilizations
they had burial mounds that had the
little they align it to the [ __ ]
stars and [ __ ] so they can shoot that
spirit up into the [ __ ] Orion's belt
what about the ones that put them on the
rack
I'm like see the fire stick road what is
that a Vikings [ __ ] funeral yeah
they've been doing that [ __ ] forever
even now this yeah yeah yeah they just
like should put them in the river I like
that and is there a guy what are ending
crossbow or like a [ __ ] arrow that's
what no but if we do that here on Venice
Beach it's like boom and then the
[ __ ] raft hits comes back to shore
they're [ __ ] burns the pier and [ __ ]
oh dude they'll be so dope no I
especially like you didn't know that the
priest kept a secret yeah dude I want to
have a funeral like that like not not a
prank funeral but like a epic like
Vikings funeral but then like I wanna
thank you huh like the like the whole
fire thing first and then you throw them
over the yakima what did you say sorry
my man weird boy I wanna be on Santa
Monica Pier and then you have a raft for
me in the form of a pirate ship and I'm
going off and then there's got to be a
homeless guy that's running down the
pier with a bungee cord charge at any
[ __ ] jumps off of here like I'm not
doing and when he then he has a lit
match and then at the end of it he dips
his lip match and he burns the [ __ ]
pirate ship and he [ __ ] tumbles back
and then everyone has a clapping [ __ ]
burns with you know he he's that's why
he's on a bungee like he's like runny
he's like riding and then he jumps and
he's like subscribed you JK news
please so you gotta hit that subscribe
button and then he [ __ ] likes the
pirate ship he jumps back yeah you
bungees back on here man so everyone's
saying farewell and then the pirate ship
is burning you got to pay these people
in advance I'm not doing it yeah I mean
that's why we find a homeless person
because he's cheaper uh and he's crazy
like he'll do it and he's athletic
enough but yeah okay have you seen
homeless people they're [ __ ] strong
really strong [ __ ] crackheads bro
okay we'll get a crackhead to do well
they're pretty Jack though a lot of the
homeless guys he'll is strong they look
like underwear models yep what kind of
underwear do you buy it look like Kanye
model no they just they're just walking
and then this guy abs and like chest and
shoulders and like nice arms she's like
why am i palms are sweaty when I stare
at this homeless guy takes my breath
away my friend has a it written in her
will for her husband that they say I
have too creamy air and put her in a
firework just stealing someone else's
ideas [ __ ] my best friend I'm allowed
to you know they could make your ashes
into a diamond that's what I want
how you compress you compress it and
Nick you have a Nash diamond door like
it's a jam or whatever order for jewel
thief steals you and then you somehow
know I've been in a drug dealer it's
gonna go into a ring and then it's gonna
go to like my like kids or someone that
body diamond that's weird would it be
engraved like seeing what it is yeah be
like I'm dead [ __ ] you aren't
you have you steal this and you became a
pimps earring a pimp I am a grill a
grill it went viral and it was tweeted
out and it was captioned with my dad's
dying wish always the prankster hmm you
got them good Papa Bear and gave us all
a laugh just when we needed it I will
love you forever
kissy face emoji hashtag Shaye's laughs
laughs I think it's tight cuz it not
every time you think back to the funeral
I remember the funeral everyone's like
has a laugh about
Yeah right cuz like don't most people
say like when I die I don't want anyone
to cry or wear black I wanted to be a
party and a celebration like I want
everyone the attrex yeah like go big
like where the [ __ ] veil like yeah
like crawl into the church can you
scream in Spanish like what forget is me
all right I want you all to be in denial
that's better so we don't even go cuz
they didn't even know it didn't happen
it's just Oh where's Cho he's on
vacation you'll be back soon you know
like a like a mom lying about an absent
father that's what I want he went out
for my grandma what yeah
cuz my grandma had Alzheimer's and the
mo my grandpa passed away she'd be like
that's one thing she remembers like
where's grandpa
well like all he went to the supermarket
I'll be back soon
she's like okay where's grandpa with the
post office I wish you remembered yeah
wouldn't you come back in this long-term
memory yeah she loved him she loved him
have you ever seen Nick Swardson stand
up about his funeral it was really funny
it's really all that's like from 2007
but yeah one thing I remember that was
really that I was like I wanna steal
that is he says he's gonna like years
before whatever like before he dies he's
gonna hire some like you know b-list
celebrity in his thing it was like John
Stamos to just show up that cry and
leave and don't say anything so it was
just kind of like oh they must knew Nick
Swardson like how did they know each
other and then everyone's really
distracted by it who would be your
celebrity I don't know it would have to
be so he's be list now No
that would be sick if you came to your
funeral do you still didn't get to meet
is that it he does a song for you I
can't wait for you I like though you
guys are all in charge of each other's
funeral you ready right I'm not doing
[ __ ] but you just said you're gonna hire
in whatever you okay I'm not going the
pirate ship I'm not getting the homeless
crackhead I'm all that's for your old
laughs you're like we need to cuz I'm
never gonna die remember he's invincible
I'm just taking a break okay oh yeah
we're gonna all be ended yeah coming
back I don't know he's at the grocery
store
yeah he went out for pack of smokes yep
[Music]
[Music]